Are you really in love with writing or have you
just got a crush on the idea of being a writer?
The reality is romantic notions of what it means
to be a writer rarely match the daily grind. But
after building my career in the world of writing,
I discovered that there's a big difference between
calling oneself a writer and actually getting
writing done. And between the wish and the thing,
there stands only one obstacle. Some call it
resistance; others, writer's block. But to
overcome it, we are going to look at it right in
the face and call it by its true name: fear. So,
in this video, I'm going to share with you eight
simple tried and true tips that genuinely helped
me overcome the fear of writing that we all go
through and that'll hopefully help you transform
from passive consumer to productive writer. And
if you're new here, my name is William. I'm an
English professor and I help non-fiction writers
write well. So, if you want to learn about the
art and science of expert writing, be sure to grab
my free newsletter, Writer Science. Link is down
below the like button. In order to understand
these eight strategies, it's important to point
out just how weird it is that in this world of
writers, we spend so much energy talking about
strategies for how to get writing done. Like,
you don't see this in any other profession.
Teachers don't talk about how hard it is to get
teaching done. We just show up, do the work, and
leave. And when you really get down to it, I think
this whole genre of writing routines and tactics
all comes down to managing the real problem that
we all have, fear. There's an old joke about a guy
who goes to a doctor and says, "Doc, it hurts
when I do this." And the doctor says, "Well,
stop doing that." And sometimes I just have to
think about taking that advice. you know, just
write the safe stuff that nobody can criticize.
It would make everything so much easier. So,
the question is, why do we keep doing it? Why
do I stop doing the thing that hurts? I mean,
it's not like this is something that's unique to
writing. Whenever I sit down to write emails or
text messages, I don't feel fear. And whenever
I worked as a copywriter, I never felt this way
about writing product descriptions. I mean, they
can be boring, but they didn't make me worry that
readers are going to hate me. So, it's only when
I want to write something that actually connects
with people that this fear sets in. Anytime I
want to write something that makes them think
differently or helps them solve a problem or just
feel less alone. But the fact is that ambition is
why I started writing online in the first place.
And without it, I'd just be adding more noise. And
I don't really think any of us want to do that.
And so what that means is everything that is weak
inside of me is fighting against this ambition,
this writing. That's the part of me that wants to
scroll social media instead of writing. The one
that whispers, "Nobody cares what you think."
And the part of me that wants to give up and just
consume other people's content forever. Now look,
your fears might be different, but here's what I
know. Every writer who's worth reading is afraid
of something. Most people who talk about starting
a newsletter or writing a blog never actually do
it. And the ones who do often quit after a
few months when they realize how hard it is
to keep going in public. But the writers who
make it aren't always the most talented ones.
They're just the ones who figured out how to live
with their fear and keep publishing anyway. So,
how do you do that? How do you keep showing up
when everything inside of you wants to hide? Well,
as everyone knows, it's helpful to set a schedule.
But how often should you write, when should you
write, and how many words per day? When William
Faulner was being interviewed by the Paris Review,
they asked him whether he writes every day or
only when he's inspired. And Faulner said, "I only
write when I'm inspired. Fortunately, I'm inspired
at 9:00 every morning." And that's a great line,
but it's worth reflecting on because, well,
look, if you only write when you're inspired,
you're never going to get it done. You know,
I once read a story about a guy who was trying
to quit smoking and he had tried all the different
tactics, you know, the patch and hypnotism and and
read all the books and everything. He would quit
smoking and then something stressful would happen
and it was always when something stressful would
happen that he would start smoking again. And so
he realizes that there is this kind of backs stop
to his quitting smoking. I'm going to quit smoking
so long as nothing stressful happens. But if you
think about it, what kind of a life is that? Like
if you were going to live the least stressful life
possible, that would be one in which both of your
parents die. So in other words, you're never going
to have an unstressful life. And so therefore,
you're never going to quit smoking by that logic.
So his epiphany was that the only way to quit
smoking is to never smoke again. And apparently
that worked for him. And I think the same thing
holds true for writers because like if your rule
is I'm only going to write so long as there's
nothing more important to do. Well, good luck with
that because there's always going to be something
more important than writing. Writing is probably
the least important thing that one could possibly
be doing. And so in order to reframe the way that
we think about writing, I think what you need to
do is invent the person who can do the writing.
And so I remember listening to an interview with
the Canadian author Sheila Hedi who spoke about
this. Not inventing the book, but inventing the
person who writes the book. Book that continues
to be the most interesting thing to think about
for me is not like the book itself, but what needs
to be done to get the book written. What kind of
person do you need to be to write this book? In
what ways do you need to trick yourself in order
to write this book? I feel like that to me is what
I think the most about. I think I don't actually
think as much about plot or character. I like
inventing the self that makes that book. And so,
how do you invent the person who can get writing
done? Well, first you need to plan for at least 2
months of serious self-discipline. That's about
the amount of time that it takes to form a new
habit. Some studies say 3 months, other studies
say 6 weeks, but I think the safest bet is to plan
for at least 2 months of a serious self-discipline
where you're ruthless. Like you are consciously
shielding and protecting this little seedling of
a plant that you're growing here, right? You want
it to have firm roots in the ground, but right
now it's a seedling and you need to protect it
from invasive species and deer who are coming to
nibble away at this not only this writing habit,
but this alter ego that you're developing. When
should you write? Well, I recommend writing in
the morning. Other people might come along with
different strategies, but look, this is what works
for me. Why does it work? Well, one, willpower is
like a muscle that gets tired throughout the day.
So you wake up with a full tank and by evening
you're running on fumes. And so if you have this
reservoir of willpower when you wake up in the
morning, then use it on this most important task,
your writing. And second, just getting writing
done early in the morning makes the rest of
your day feel like a victory lap. If you've ever
tried to enjoy your evening when you know that you
still have something to write, it's impossible.
But if you finish your writing in the morning,
then everything else feels like a reward.
How long should you write during these daily
writing sessions? Well, I think 30 minutes a day
is fantastic if you're busy. And if you can manage
an hour on your good days, then you're doing
great. During busy periods when I'm teaching,
I'll write in three 90minute sessions with breaks
in between just as I'm waiting between classes.
But honestly, the exact timing doesn't matter as
much as having a pattern. It's just about finding
something that works for you. Some people like
doing this pomodoro technique where you use these
25 minute timers of, you know, focused work
and then a five minute break. Uh, one tactic
that I was using this winter was uh this chess
timer. This is actually kind of cool. I'm not
using it so much these days, but but during the
winter holiday whenever I I was off from school,
I had a lot more time to write during the day.
And so I would use this chest timer. I'd have
uh 4 hours here and 4 and 1/2 hours there. And
my goal was to have four hours of concentrated uh
writing time. And so I would just have this timer
going and it would countdown and anytime I took
the this would be the the break timer. So anytime
I took the slightest break, I would just flip that
on and then I would have 4 and 1/2 hour uh as
a break and uh 4 hours of concentrated writing
time. And so the goal was just to count down the
4 hours before the 4 and 1/2 hours counted down.
And so it kind of gified it for me. I did that for
a few months. It worked great. But the point here
is just to find what works for you, but make it
consistent. Consistency is everything, especially
as you're developing this new practice. It can
be helpful to tell people about your pattern,
but be careful whenever you announce it to people.
If you write about it on social media or something
like that or you tell people in your life, don't
focus on the outcome. Like don't tell people that
you're writing a book. Tell people that you are
writing for 90 minutes a day. I've seen people
who announce kind of grand projects they're going
to be taking on. And one I've heard that there's
this psychological phenomena where your brain
can't really tell the difference between uh
pursuing a goal and announcing that you're going
to achieve it. And so you kind of like tap out
some of your emotional reserves or something like
that. Um, but also it can just kind of make this
feel like so much bigger of an undertaking than it
really needs to be. So don't tell people what your
project is necessarily, but do tell people about
the habit that you're starting to develop. Because
I think when you narrate your process to other
people, it becomes real like it stands outside of
your mood and motivation. There have been times
when I become quite inspired and I set out big
90-day writing goals for myself and inevitably
that peters out. So, it's quite helpful to have
somebody to hold you accountable and it's great
if they can follow up with you and just kind of
hold you to it. How much should you write? Well,
uh word counts can be tricky. If it works for you,
that's great. I used to obsess over word counts,
but honestly, that made me crazy. So now I just
aim for about two pages a day whenever I have
the time. And if that's not working for me,
I'll just focus on completing my writing sessions.
You know, Jerry Seinfeld has whenever he was
developing his writing practice, he would
set a timer for I don't remember how long,
two hours or something like that. And his rule was
that he didn't have to write during this time, but
he couldn't do anything other than write. And so
if you're really not hitting your writing goals,
if you really can't hit that word count, then it's
quite enough to just sit in that undistracted time
that's reserved for writing. After a very short
period of doing nothing, if if you're not allowing
yourself to switch between Twitter and and other
distracting elements, and you're just sitting
there with the writing, well, eventually you're
going to find something to write about. Some days
you're going to need to revise what you've already
written before moving forward. And that counts,
too. We're going to talk about that a little bit
more, but we don't have to think about writing as
being this purely novel output thing. Writing
is recursive. So, we'll come back to that in a
moment. But for now, let's just do a little
arithmetic. All right. So if you can average
just two pages a day during these focused writing
periods, then you can finish a book draft in about
four to 5 months, right? So if you want to write
a,000 words a day, which is about two pages, break
that down into 250 words, you want four writing
sessions of 250 words. So if you have these 25
minute writing sessions, that's 10 words a minute.
So do you think that in a 25minut writing session
you could handle writing one sentence or 10 words
per minute? If you can just break it down to that
level, write 10 words a minute for 2 hours,
that'll give you enough for a rough draft of
a manuscript. But honestly, the best thing about
developing this daily writing habit isn't just the
pages that you produce. It's actually knowing when
you're allowed to stop. Like if you don't have
these guard rails on your writing practice, then
it's very easy to constantly feel guilty about all
the time and all the days when you could have
been writing more. But once you establish this
daily writing practice, then it's very easy to
know exactly when you're finished. So, you just
show up, start your timer, 10 words a minute, hit
your time goal or your word goal, and then you can
enjoy the rest of your day without this nagging
voice telling you that you should be working.
That's why I write in a specific place as well. It
just helps to build the habit, but it also creates
clear boundaries because whenever I'm not in my
writing space, I'm not supposed to be working.
I'm free to actually live my life. But let's be
honest, whether you are writing for a time goal
or you're aiming for a word count, there are going
to be days when you miss your goal. And we need to
learn how to manage those days because unmet goals
do not create habits. There's the story about
Victor Hugo who used to have himself locked in his
room and he ordered his servants to only let him
out whenever he would pass the finished pages,
whatever his daily output goal was underneath
the door. That was the only way that he could open
that door. And that might be a little bit extreme,
but it does illustrate this idea of the goal being
nonnegotiable. You do want that kind of container
for your practice, something that will not let you
break out of it. But of course, you don't want to
be extreme about this. And so, well, like him
or hate him, I think there's a really good take
on this principle that comes from Jordan Peterson.
Aim low. And I I don't mean don't aim. And I don't
mean don't aim up. You can set yourself a goal
that you can attain and there's not going to be
much glory in it to begin with. It's one step
on a very long journey. And so it's it and it
starts to compound on you. So a small step today
means puts you in a position to take a slightly
bigger step the next day. And then that puts you
in a position to take a slightly bigger step the
next day. And you do that for 2 or 3 years, man,
you're starting to stride. All right? So aim low.
Like you absolutely have to focus on small, easily
achievable goals. Don't plan to write 2,000 words
a day. Don't try to write for 4 hours straight.
Just focus on slow and steady because your goal
is not to become this writing machine like Stephen
King who just has this incredible output. Your
job is to become a goal meeting person. Remember
you are trying to invent the person who can get
writing done and that person meets goals. In the
book Atomic Habits, James Clear tells this story
of somebody who is trying to develop the habit
of going to the gym. And for the first couple of
weeks, he actually would go to the gym and not
work out. He would go to the gym, get into his
clothes, and then pack them up and go back home.
And that's because it wasn't about the exercise.
It was about transforming himself into a gymgoing
person. And so that's what we really need to do
at the beginning. It's like start small. Can you
have 15 minutes of totally focused time? Can you
write one sentence a day? Can you become a goal
meeting person? It doesn't matter what the goal
is because if you can just meet these small goals,
then it creates this pattern of self-motivation
and reward that will keep you moving forward. And
look, missing the occasional goal is not going to
hurt your habit building, but making a huge deal
out of it, that's what kills your momentum. So,
here's how you can start making small goals
and meeting them. First, you've got to forgive
yourself immediately whenever you miss a day. You
don't abandon a diet because you had a burger at a
barbecue. You don't quit learning guitar because
you missed practice on Tuesday. Don't let these
small lapses destroy the whole system. Second,
look forward. Like, if you can't shake the guilt,
just focus on meeting today's goal and feeling
good about it. Third, do not add today's gap
to tomorrow's task. Like, if you had a goal of
500 words and you only wrote 300 words today,
that doesn't mean that you have to write 700
words tomorrow. And I think this is where goals
and habit systems get destroyed because it's a
lot harder to sit down to write 700 words than
it is 500 words. So if you carry today's gap to
tomorrow's goal, then you're just going to make
the habit that much harder to start. Those extra
words have a way of spiraling out of control.
And pretty soon you're looking at a day where you
think you need to catch up by writing 3,000 words.
And you need to find ways to celebrate whenever
you hit your targets. That could mean taking a day
off if you meet your writing goal. Or you could
just have a day where you write, but you're not
tracking anything and so you kind of rejuvenate
the freedom that you feel in the craft. Some of
my best work has come from these bonus days where
I was just writing for the joy of it. Finally,
just go easy on yourself. I don't know who needs
to hear this. Maybe I'm just talking to myself
with this one, but there might be others of you
out there who get this kind of self-disiplining
drill sergeant voice in your ear. And I think
we just need to let go of all that and focus
on building the habit. Right? One danger in this
world of writing advice is that we can try to trap
ourselves in these routines and you know brick
our phone and be like Hugo and lock ourselves in
a room and this can be very selfdestructive
and destructive to the practice as well.
Like I really think for this to work, it has to
be fun. And writing is fun. You know, this whole
video is talking about the fear of writing and the
pain of it all. And so many writers really like
to talk about that loneliness and isolation,
but god for this to work, it has to be fun,
right? You don't hear painters talking about the
torment of going to their studio and playing with
the paint. You don't hear sculptors talk about
it. Okay? The writing is our craft and we need
to find some joy and freedom in it for this to
be a sustainable relationship. Like I don't want
to live in a world where part of me is constantly
screaming at another part of me like some deranged
drill sergeant. And like this part of you that
wants to write, that's a good part of you. We
want to nurture that part of you. So you don't
want to turn your relationship with that part
of yourself and and with your writing into this
negative experience. We really need to, you know,
as we're developing this habit system, the point
is through the habit to discover the pleasure of
writing. That's why we're doing this. And so treat
yourself or that part of you like someone you
actually care about, someone you want to nurture
and somebody you want to feel comfortable and and
welcome back the next time. And look, you're
going to get stuck. It's not a matter of if,
it's when. Sometimes you're going to get stuck on
the big picture. You might be a few weeks into a
project and suddenly you think, "This is garbage.
The whole premise is flawed. I need to start
over." Other times you'll get stuck in the moment
of your writing practice. You'll be sitting there
staring at a screen, feeling like you're moving
backwards, unable to write a single line. And
the solution to both problems is exactly the same.
Keep writing. For those moments when you're stuck
in the middle of a writing session, try this. Open
a new document and just start typing whatever's in
your head for 5 or 10 minutes. Usually, I'll begin
with something like, "Okay, I'm stuck on this
piece and I can't figure out how to dot da da."
Right? Whatever you do, just don't stop typing.
Just as a quick analogy here, this is a practice
that I teach in my English as a foreign language
class. I work with students uh here in Korea who
have high knowledge of English and low fluency.
So, they know they can pass tests, but they have a
hard time expressing themselves and they get stuck
just like you and I do. And so, this is actually a
very easy problem to fix. And after a few of these
writing sessions, their uh this is fluency. Their
fluency increases exponentially. And so what you
do is you just set a timer and you write anything
that comes to mind. Anything. You could repeat
yourself if you want. You could write I don't know
what to write about. If you want, you could write
I am trying to write about this and I'm feeling
stuck about that. It almost doesn't matter. The
point is that it's just this fresh writing session
where your only goal is to not stop typing. Now,
of course, you know, you want to be writing
coherently. You want to be writing sentences
and not just random. You're not just smashing
the keyboard, if you follow my drift. But the
point is that it doesn't matter what you write
so long as you don't stop writing. And after 5
or 10 minutes of this, you're often going to find
your way into a solution or at least that you'll
notice that your rambling suddenly starts to veer
into actual focused writing and soon you're back
in the flow of your real project. And this is an
important substitution because like my impulse
whenever I feel stuck writing is to get up,
walk away from the computer, go to the kitchen,
and have a spoonful of peanut butter. That's
my coping mechanism for this feeling of being
stuck. But now, whenever I feel my legs starting
to lift me out of the chair, I just make myself
sit there for 5 or 10 minutes more and write
a few random sentences. Nine times out of 10,
this breaks me through. Now, for bigger problems,
whenever you've lost faith in the whole project,
try this. Go back and reread everything that
you've written. Now, don't just skim it.
really read it like you're encountering it for
the first time. And what I often find when I
do this is that it's better than you thought or
you're going to start to see exactly where things
are going sideways. The problem here is that as a
writer, you're experiencing this text as a writer.
And so the way this process works is you go back
to the beginning and experience it as a reader,
going through line by line, not just skimming
it, but really kind of reading it and trying to
follow the thought process of the person who wrote
it. Because as you go through those sentences,
you'll start to encounter their your their thought
process and you'll start to see where they went
wrong. And once you've done this, what you can do
is write an outline of what you actually have and
not just what you plan to write. Like as you've
been reading this, you're now encountering it as
a reader would. And so you can start to describe
the logic that you see developing. This is going
to help you identify where the holes are and the
parts that you need to fill in. And you'll start
to see, oh, well, wait a second. This part
doesn't belong there. and aha like then you
start to discover where the whole piece started
going sideways. So this is a matter of changing
your perspective from the sentence level to the
structure level and once you can perceive that
structure in those larger units of discourse
then you can start to fix it. Like whenever
you get these macro problems where you feel like
a piece just isn't working. That's usually not
something that you can resolve at the sentence
level. You need to resolve it at the structural
level. And so what this practice lets you do
is start to identify the structure and you can
start to see where things aren't really fitting
together in these larger units of discourse. Now,
if you've tried both of those techniques and
you're still stuck, then it can often be helpful
to find somebody to talk through it with. And this
is where a lot of us mess up. We only want to show
our work when we're proud of it. And in my writing
consultations, I can often tell when writers are
struggling because they start avoiding certain
parts of feedback. Like their work isn't going
well. So, they start to feel guilty about that
and they want to solve everything before anyone
sees it. But that's like going to the doctor only
when you're healthy. Like, if you don't share your
struggles, then nobody can help you through them.
So, you want to find people whose opinions you can
trust and who can give you the kind of advice that
actually helps. Sometimes that can be a writing
group. And if you have one of these, then count
yourself really lucky. But I've got to say, like
whenever these groups get too big, like more than
three or four people, the advice generally gets a
little bit too polite and too vague. The best is
sharing one-on-one if you can find somebody to do
it. This can be close friends or just anybody
who will tell you the truth. But above all,
the point here is just to not give up. We writers
have evolved beyond basic procrastination. We're
not binge watching Netflix or scrolling Tik Tok
for hours. We're more refined than that. No, no,
that won't do. We have moved on to the advanced
stuff. Call it virtuous procrastination. You know
what I'm talking about. Cleaning the house instead
of writing, organizing your desk. These things
feel productive, so they don't trigger the same
guilt as obvious time wasting. But the truth is,
if writing terrifies you, then cleaning
your house feels like a vacation. Ah, yes,
it's the messy desk that stopped me from writing.
The dishes in the sink, that's what'll get me
writing. But the fact is that you probably created
that mess unconsciously to avoid sitting down at
your computer. The sneakiest form of virtuous
procrastination is work that feels important. And
so the appeal here is obvious. These tasks make
you feel productive and they have deadlines and
clear outcomes which is a lot better than the kind
of vague neverending toil that we have whenever
we're writing. Like writing by contrast it makes
you feel uncertain and vulnerable. And until the
piece is done it's not really serving anybody else
except for you and your vision. If you're an indie
writer, then nobody's demanding that you publish
that piece today except you. And you are the
easiest person to convince otherwise. And since
you're a oneperson business, marketing and writing
are both part of building your platform. So, it's
easy to convince yourself that spending 3 hours
on your Instagram strategy or catching up on the
news on Twitter is just as valuable as writing,
but it's not. choosing the easier task because
it feels safer and it mitigates your fear of
writing. I swear my job as a writing coach
is like 90% psychology. And so, of course,
all of these things are part of your business. And
I'm not going to say here that you should neglect
them. Do a decent job with the business stuff,
but don't forget what you actually want to be
known for. You want to be known for your business
strategy, your SEO. No, you want to be known for
your ideas, for your voice and your perspective.
And that only comes from one place, sitting down
and getting writing done. But the flip side of
this problem is just as dangerous. That's writers
who can't stop working on their projects. These
writers get stuck in endless research and revision
cycles because they're terrified of putting their
work out there. So, as long as it's not finished,
it can't be judged. Oh god, I went through this
so much in university and professors would always
give me deadlines. I just need a few more days
and then my term paper will be perfect. But I
swear that's like giving a drunk a drink. And
the logic here is quite clever because as long
as more research could be done, then the work
is still in its perfect potential. You know that
flawless piece that you have in your imagination,
it stays there crystallized instead of coming into
the world in its flawed form. So look, whatever
you're working on, it's not your magnum opus.
It's just your next work. And one thing I've been
discovering in this practice of writing and making
videos online is that letting it go and having it
be evaluated, as painful as that moment is, will
teach you so much more about writing than another
month of polishing. Now, look, you're going to
procrastinate. You're human. You're going to find
creative ways to avoid the hard work all the time.
But the goal is getting better at catching
yourself sooner. And full transparency, of course,
I still procrastinate. Usually I do it by reading
too much or letting admin tasks eat up my time.
But the only difference is that I recognize it
faster. Now, and I have habits that pull me back
to the actual writing. One of the best tools here
is talking to other writers about how your work is
going. In my case, I have a colleague that I can
talk to. And it's just so funny. Like the lies you
tell yourself to avoid the fear of writing just
sound ridiculous whenever you say them out loud
to someone else. Like, "Hey, how'd that newsletter
go last week? Oh, I can't I couldn't work on it
because I need to redesign my website first. Oh,
I'm not ready to publish it because I haven't done
enough research." Do you hear how silly that
sounds? Good. Now, go write something. Ah,
but you're still here, aren't you? And you're
still afraid of writing. Well, a lot of people
think that the goal is to stop being afraid of
writing, but in this video, I'm saying something
completely different. I'm saying any writing that
aims to be great will always be frightening. Like,
if you're aiming for greatness, if you're aiming
for that great vision of something that you have
in your mind, that vision is going to challenge
you to do your best work and it forces you to
face the possibility that you might not live up to
those dreams. And so that fear of writing is not
going anywhere. I mean, I suppose maybe somewhere
out there there's a writer who feels no fear,
but I imagine fearless writing as complacent
writing. And look, to be frank, there are a lot
of writers out there, you can probably think
of a few, who are just too confident and too
sure of themselves to be surprised by any new
ideas. So these supremely confident writers,
the ones who never feel fear before they hit
publish, there's nothing you can learn from them.
And that's the reason why no one fears writing
emails because they don't aim for perfection.
They just aim for information transfer. But the
best writing, the kind of writing that I think
you and I are aspiring to is that which generates
new knowledge. It causes a a a surprise discovery
in the writer and it's written in such a way to
deliver that discovery as a gift to the reader.
That kind of writing is always going to be
driven by fear. And I don't think we're ever
really going to extinguish that fear. It's tied in
with the aspiration of writing something true and
valuable. So instead, what we need to do is make
fear an ally, right? So if you really think about
this fear as a character or like an animating
force within you, then you want to not fight it,
but instead use it as a signal. Oh, there's
this great quote by a Buddhist nun named Pemma
and she says something like fear is a signal that
you're moving closer to the truth. All right? So,
whenever you feel that fear, don't fight it, but
use it to show you the opportunities in your work.
All right? And whenever you're stuck and you're
trying to break through it in one of these quick
writing sessions, what you can ask yourself is,
what am I most afraid of here? What scares me
about this paragraph? Why am I stuck here? I now
have an image of like somebody on the beach with,
you know, one of those beach comrs with a
metal detector, right? Like fear should be
the beep beep beep that you're you're you're
uncovering something valuable here. And so you
should write about that fear and and follow its
thread because underneath it like it's linked to
something. It's linked to something important.
Instead of seeing it as an obstacle, imagine it
pointing to the most interesting problem in your
work. All right. Here's another way that you can
use fear in your writing. Keep enough of it alive
to make your writing interesting. Like we always
say writing is thinking. Writing is thinking. But
if that's true, like if you really believe that,
then it's also true that if you sit down and
you know already what your conclusion is,
then what's the point of writing that? There's
no discovery. There's no thought in it. The idea
is dead on arrival. Maybe this is just a personal
preference, but I prefer writing that stays open
to learning something new. Now, sometimes whenever
I'm writing and I'm a few pages into a piece, I'll
stumble onto a really good idea, one that would
be a perfect ending for the whole piece. Now,
if this ever happens to you, I think the instinct
is to save it and then build towards it. You know,
writing confidently, knowing where you're
going to finish the piece. But these days,
whenever that happens, I force myself to write
that idea down immediately right there on the
page. And so instead of saving this best
piece for last, I just kind of position it
as it occurs to me. And this forces me to find
something even better for the ending. I mean,
that's the rule, right? Like your your best idea
can't be buried there in the middle. And so it's a
little challenge to myself like if this gem of an
idea is positioned there in the middle of a piece
then I have to keep thinking and keep discovering.
This kind of writing is like wy coyote you know
running off the cliff and then building the bridge
frantically just ahead of my feet. Now there is a
piece of writing advice that we need to address
and that is about being concise. Every writing
guide out there will tell you to cut ruthlessly.
Use fewer words. Trim the fat. And this advice
isn't wrong, but it misses something crucial.
You cannot worry about concision when you've
just started writing. Think about it like money.
Whenever you're broke, buying someone lunch feels
impossible because you barely have enough to feed
yourself. But whenever you're rich, you can pick
up the check for everyone at the table. It's the
same thing with writing. You can only afford to
cut when you have plenty to spare. Like cutting
10 pages from a 20page draft is a disaster, but
it's not really a big deal to cut 50 pages from a
200page manuscript. So I found that if you start
following this advice of concision and pruning too
early, then you're going to slow yourself down and
miss the chance that one of those wordy paragraphs
contains the next big idea. like this advice about
concision. It's a good point of writing style,
but I think in practice it becomes this dangerous
psychological pattern where it becomes almost like
self-punishment disguised as virtue. It's almost
like writing anorexia. You know, you're holding
yourself to these impossible standards that nobody
else believes in. No matter what you're writing,
I think it's really important to write without
knowing exactly how things are going to turn out.
You really got to let yourself learn as you go and
follow ideas wherever they lead, wherever they
come from, who knows. This is a mode that I call
shifting between the artist and the architect. The
artist is just a channel for these ideas to come
through. And it's really important to give them
life and give them space and just get out of their
way. And then eventually you can step back as the
architect and see how everything hangs together.
Some pages aren't going to fit in the final
shape, and that's fine. But by that point,
you'll have so much material that you can
afford to be generous with your cuts. Now,
one piece of advice I came across recently is that
there needs to be a separation between writing and
revision. First, you write, then you fix what's
broken. But as anybody who actually understands
writing can confirm, that's completely backwards.
If you want to create something meaningful,
real writing is recursive. Whenever I work,
I pause after each section or paragraph, read
back what I've written, and this helps me see what
I've actually accomplished and start mapping the
shape of the whole piece. But more importantly,
it helps me find my best ideas. Now, since I don't
really censor much in my first drafts, my writing
usually contains multiple ideas. Some that are
connected to others, others that are just floating
around orphaned. And whenever I reread and revise,
I hunt for these strongest thoughts and start
building the structure around those concepts.
The weaker stuff just gets cut or saved for later.
So this process of freewriting and then hunting
for the key ideas and structuring. This creates
a feedback loop. The structure that emerges from
the revision shows me where the next sections need
to go. The closer I get to finishing, the more I
understand what the piece needs to be complete.
So, here's what this means practically. If you
write this way, then revision isn't something
that happens after writing. Revision is writing.
The act of revision creates the text just as much
as those first sentences that you put down. Most
people learn about editing and revision in school
as fixing whatever the teacher marked as wrong.
So correcting grammar or maybe adding a paragraph
here or there. And I think that teaches you two
things. One, it teaches you that revision is
something that happens to a static complete text.
And two, it teaches you that revision happens at a
separate moment from the writing process. But real
revision is dynamic. It's discovering what you
actually are trying to say. And I'm going to go
farther and say that it might actually be helpful
to think of research in the same way. Like I used
to separate research days from writing days, but
the more I think about it, the more that's totally
artificial. Some of your best ideas might come
from browsing, reading, or just taking notes. And
I think it's only fair to treat those moments of
discovery as part of the writing process itself.
So consider giving yourself credit for research
as part of your writing practice. Include it in
your goals and your habits. And if you need
to spend 2 hours reading and taking notes,
I think that counts as writing time. But be
careful. Research is also one of the classic
forms of virtuous procrastination. So what's
the difference between productive research and
procrastination? Well, I think it's whether
the research is moving your current project
forward or if it's just making you feel busy. When
you're reading to understand something specific,
something that your piece needs, that's writing.
But when you're reading just because you're trying
to avoid the negative feelings connected
to the blank page, that's avoidance. So,
I think the key here is just integration. Writing,
researching, revising, they're all part of the
same idea generation process. They all involve
discovery and they all move your work forward.
So stop thinking of revision as cleanup duty and
start thinking of it as the place where your real
ideas emerge. Finally, last point, I just need to
say that, you know, this genre that we're kind of
in here on writing YouTube, this genre of writing
advice, it's really like self-help for writers. We
read guides to writing by Stephen King or Annie
Dillard because we think that it has the secret
that we need to get unstuck. But the simple fact
is that the thing that's got you stuck is fear.
So take this advice. I'm going to be honest with
you. Most of the people won't actually try any of
the things that we've shared in this video. I've
worked with writers who listen to these ideas with
genuine excitement. They nod along and say, "Yes,
yes, writing every day. 30 minutes sounds perfect.
Yes, I'm totally going to do that." And they
don't. And I think this happens for two reasons.
First, they don't quite believe I actually do
these things myself. And so, they think this
advice is maybe for beginners, for people who
don't have their act together. And since their
goal is eventually to not need systems and habits,
they figure that they should start practicing the
advanced stuff right now. But of course, this
is completely backwards. Whenever I'm working on
something important, I do everything that I've
described here exactly as I've described it.
And this really is my grownup professional
writing practice for whatever it's worth. I'm
not making up training wheels for amateurs. And
the second reason why I think they don't follow
this advice is that following it consistently is
hard. As we said at the beginning, it takes about
2 months to build an automatic habit. That's two
months of serious willpower and discipline with
constant opportunities to backslide, get caught
in emotional traps, or just get taken over by new
priorities. So, I get it. This stuff is hard.
But here's what you need to know. It does get
easier. Not easy, but easier. the habits become
more automatic and the resistance that you feel
becomes less strong and you start to trust that
the process works. So the only advice that I can
give you is to trust yourself enough to try it.
Start small. Pick one thing and commit to it for
a week. If that works, try another week. Don't let
small lapses convince you to give up entirely. And
please be good to yourself. Make friends with
your anxiety and your fear. Don't fight them.
That's part of you and they're trying to tell you
something. And remember that every professional
writer who you admire has felt exactly what you're
feeling right now. They might not admit to it in
their author interviews in print, but be assured
they do. And the only difference between the
professional writers and the ones who want to
write is that they kept going. So start small,
really small. Write a comment below and let
me know which one of these tips you're going
to try. A thousand words a day. It's not much,
but it's honest work and should hopefully get
you started writing today. But you might be
tempted to speed this up by outsourcing the
work of writing to AI. And while that does punch
up your word count, it's also going to dilute the
value of your writing. So watch this video next
because it's going to give you my plugandplay
system for writing valuable non-fiction
without AI. So be sure to go check it out.